die erste frage an sie wir haben gerade
mit herrn bergmann gesprochen er ist
ehemaliger familien und
vormundschaftsrichter und er sagt diese
diskussion um schärfere gesetze
schärfere strafen ist unsinnig man
müsste erst mal die jetzigen gesetze und
strafen ausschöpfen das würde nämlich
nicht geschehen warum geschieht das
nicht und liegt herr bergmann aus ihrer
sicht mit seiner einschätzung richtig
ich fange mal mit dem zweiten teil der
frage an herbert man es gibt sicherlich
nicht uneingeschränkt richtig mit seiner
einschätzung
ich selber habe bevor ich versteh's
ministerin wurde über 30 jahre als
richterin in meiner tätigkeit circa zehn
jahre davon sexuellen missbrauch
verhandelt und weiß sehr wohl immer um
die einzelfall problematik und die frage
der ausschöpfung von straff rahmen
aber natürlich muss man darüber
nachdenken ob unser strafmaß unser
strafräumen der jetzt im strafgesetzbuch
steht so ausreicht ich bin der
auffassung dass man da durchaus
zumindest bei den mindeststrafen was
machen muss im moment gehen wir bei
einem teil der missbrauchs gerade um
kinderpornografischen bereich straftaten
noch bei einer mindeststrafe von sechs
monaten das ist aus meiner sicht zu
wenig man muss eindeutig da den
strafräumen anheben und auf eine
mindeststrafe von einem jahr gegeben
weil das schon dann auch automatisch zu
einem verbrechen nun nicht mehr nur zu
einem vergehen wird das ist aus meiner
sicht ganz wichtig die frage die da
hinter sich verbirgt ist ja aber immer
hat es eine abschreckungswirkung und da
bin ich auch bei herrn bergmann de mich
aufmerksam zugehört habe ein
abschreckungseffekt beobachten wir bei
vielen straftaten nicht ein täter der
entschlossen ist lässt sich meistens
durch die strafen nicht abschrecken aber
er muss dann eben entsprechend auch
hinterher mit wenn er erwischt wird mit
strafen entsprechender höhe rechnen
und jetzt gibt es ja auch immer wieder
den fall von bewährungsstrafen wenn's um
missbrauch kinderpornographie geht sich
gehört das nicht komplett abgeschafft
na ja also das ist dann muss man eben in
die juristische argumentation gehen und
auch in die systematik unserer
strafgesetze eine freiheitsstrafe bis zu
zwei jahren kann eben zur bewährung
ausgesetzt werden unter bestimmten
voraussetzungen das ist dann immer
jeweils auf diese voraussetzungen
vorliegen die individuelle entscheidung
des tat richters oder der kammer die
dass die die tat ab urteilt unser system
unser strafsystem geht zunächst mal
davon aus dass unter bestimmten
voraussetzungen die der mensch sich noch
bewähren kann und diese chance über
einen gewissen zeitraum ein straffreies
leben zu führen und sich ordnungsgemäß
zu präsentieren bekommen soll
das ist erstmal der grundsatz dass ist
immer besonders schwierig und das sehe
ich auch so
bei taten die uns alle furchtbar auch
emotional anrühren und abschrecken und
besonders widerwärtig sind gleichwohl
sieht unser system unser strafsystem
unter strafgesetzbuch ist sehr
ausgewogen auch unter berücksichtigung
der grundrechte die auch der täter ja
hat ist so ausgelegt dass man im grunde
sagt wenn jemand die voraussetzungen
mitbringt muss man zumindest die
möglichkeit der strafaussetzung zur
bewährung prüfen
also es ist immer schwer natürlich
nachvollziehen wenn man von solchen
fällen hört und dann dem ja der tat dann
gegenübergestellt wird da gab es dann
eine strafe auf bewährung geben sie
haben abschreckung angesprochen braucht
es jetzt um wirklich abzuschrecken eine
gesetzesinitiative für lebenslänglich
für kinderschänder kann man nicht so ein
signal in der gesellschaft setzen wir
tolerieren das nicht es gibt kein
verjähren zum beispiel und es gibt eine
maximalstrafe die auch wirklich die
maximalstrafe ist die wir in unserem
rechtssystem kennen weil das vergehen an
kindern einfach
ein maximal vergehen dass kate nash
darstellt in unserer gesellschaft also
mit dieser mit ihrem letzten satz bin
ich vollständig bei ihnen sexueller
missbrauch das hat irgendwas von von
mord an der kinderseele zu tun und haben
auch damit zu tun ist es auch je nachdem
wie schwer der missbrauch ausfällt über
welchen zeitraum mehr aufgelaufen ist
das sind alles auch forderungen die ich
nachvollziehen kann und auf die ideen
kann man auch kommen
gleichwohl das muss man natürlich auch
immer im genau sehen wir haben eine im
sexuellen missbrauch ein straff rahmen
der im höchstmaß 15 jahre beträgt bis
schwere fälle sind und wir alle wissen
dass sexuelle missbrauchstaten auch
unterschiedlich schwer sind deswegen die
forderung pauschal immer lebenslänglich
für missbrauch würde so nicht hinkommen
wir müssen einfach sehen dass wir unser
das gesamte schritt so alt strafrecht
mit seinen strafen und auch einer
ausdifferenzierung auf den prüfstand
stellen
da nicht auch ein gesetzespaket seit
längerer zeit und ein entwurf mit
entsprechenden expertise beim
bundesjustizministerium und darauf
warten wir auch denn da muss dringend
etwas passieren
ich bin vollkommen einer meinung mit
ihnen und in meinen vorrednern dass wir
sehr genau hinsehen müssen dass kindern
den so etwas widerfährt auch eine hohe
adäquate angemessene und auch sehr
spürbare strafe entgegengesetzt werden
muss